You guys made another listener.
你们又收获了一位听众。
When I was born, I was born with a medical condition known as 222 deletion, which is missing the 22nd chromosome.
我出生时患有一种叫作22q缺失的医疗状况，也就是缺失了第22号染色体。
With that, it gave me a congenital heart defect, and I've been through so much physical and health issues.
因此，我患上了先天性心脏病，经历了无数的身体和健康问题。
However, because of all of that, I never felt like I actually belonged anywhere.
然而，正因为这一切，我从来没觉得自己真正属于任何地方。
How I met your mother has changed my life, because we watch it on a yearly basis.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》改变了我的人生，因为我们每年都会重温它。
I'm gonna be watching it right now as I chat with you guys about this.
我跟你们聊这些的时候，现在就准备边看边聊。
And I just find so much inspiration from the show.
我从这部剧中找到了太多的灵感。
I find so much inspiration from the actors.
我从这些演员身上找到了太多的灵感。
I've learned to be a better friend, a better partner, and just a better person.
我学会了做一个更好的朋友、更好的伴侣，以及一个更好的人。
Because of this show, it's always a reminder of how to handle problems.
因为这部剧，它一直在提醒我该如何处理问题。
Thank you for changing my life.
谢谢你们改变了我的人生。
Thank you.
谢谢你们。
I'm alone, won't be soon, book city, when I see you.
我很孤独，但不会太久，书城，当我见到你时。
Please permit me to tell you everything for York City.
请允许我告诉你关于纽约的一切。
Welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看另一期的《我们是如何创造你老爸的》。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hey, Craig.
嘿，克雷格。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
Hey, Alex, are you still trying?
嘿，亚历克斯，你还在忍耐吗？
I'm still trying not to cry at the open a show crying.
我还在努力克制，不在开场时哭出来。
Feels very unprofessional.
开场就哭感觉太不专业了。
Usually I get you about three quarters of the way through.
通常我能坚持到差不多四分之三过去。
That was such a lovely letter.
那真是一封动人的信。
I saw you, I knew that landed on you, Craig.
我看得出来，克雷格，这触动了你。
It did.
确实如此。
I'm trying to get my ass together.
我正在努力平复心情。
Thank you so much for that beautiful message.
非常感谢你发来这么美好的信息。
My son, Elliot, he has a rare genetic syndrome.
我的儿子埃利奥特，他患有一种罕见的综合征。
It's a deletion on one of his 11th chromosomes.
他的其中一条11号染色体有一段缺失。
I've talked about it on the show.
我在节目中谈过这个。
I wrote a novel inspired by my son and the idea that how I met your mother and now this podcast is speaking to somebody who has gone through challenges and has gone through health and heart challenges.
我写了一部小说，灵感来自于我的儿子，以及《老爸老妈浪漫史》乃至现在的这个播客，正在与经历过挑战、健康和心脏挑战的人产生共鸣的这种想法。
my son had opened hard surgery at two weeks old, just to know that the show has meant something and been a place of belonging and connection for you.
我儿子在两周大时就做过心脏直胸手术，只要一想到这部剧对你意义重大，曾为你提供了一个归属感和连接感的地方，
It just means the world.
这就意味着全世界。
Thank you so much for that message.
非常感谢你发来这条信息。
I love how he said he rewatches it every year.
我很喜欢他说他每年都会重温这部剧。
It's so funny that this show was inspired by, what's his name from It's Wonderful Life?
真搞笑，这部剧的灵感居然来自于，叫什么名字来着，来自《生活多美好》的那位？
Jimmy Stewart's character?
詹姆斯·斯图尔特的角色？
George Bailey.
乔治·贝利。
George Bailey, thank you.
乔治·贝利，谢谢。
George Bailey and also Christmas story looms very large.
乔治·贝利，还有《圣诞故事》也占有很重的分量。
So these yearly things that people rewatch over and over and, you know, like to mark the season's passing, how I met your mother in a much longer way, because it's obviously longer than those two movies.
所以这些人们一遍又一遍重温的年度节目，你知道的，就像是为了标志着季节的更替，《老爸老妈浪漫史》以一种长得多的方式，因为它显然比那两部电影要长。
It's not as compact of a rewatch.
重温起来没那么紧凑。
Yeah, has become an annual thing for people to do to watch the show, which is so great.
对，它已经成为人们每年都要做的事情，去观看这部剧，这真是太棒了。
And I hope our rewatch podcast is accompanying you on your 50th or 20th or 10th or first watch or rewatch.
我希望我们的重温播客能陪伴你进行第50次、第20次、第10次或第1次观看或重温。
We're so happy to be continuing to do this.
我们很高兴能继续做这件事。
I would say we're now like, we're really deep into season three.
我想说我们现在，我们已经真正深入到第三季了。
We are in.
我们开始了。
Before we move on, again, thank you for the message.
在我们继续之前，再次感谢你的留言。
I just wanted to say that the hometown charitable cause of how we made your mother is raising money for an amazing doctor who researches pediatric congenital heart disease.
我只想说，《我们是如何创造你老爸的》的家乡慈善事业是为一位研究儿童先天性心脏病的杰出医生筹集资金。
So like literally what this wonderful person has been through and my son has been through.
所以这字面意思上就是这位了不起的人和我的儿子所经历过的事情。
So I just want to say that that if you go to how we made your mother.com, you go to what is it, Alex, is it giving, or is it making a difference tab at the top?
所以我想说，如果你访问 how we made your mother.com，你访问的是什么，亚历克斯，是捐赠，还是顶部的“产生影响”标签？
Go find, make a difference on the website, and you can donate to work that helps people with congenital heart disease.
去网站上找“产生影响”，你就可以为帮助先天性心脏病患者的事业捐款。
So yeah, I just wanted to give a little shout out to that as our cause, I'm so glad we are finding fans that's doomed that speaks, and it just means the world to me.
所以，是的，我只想向它致敬，作为我们的慈善事业，我很高兴我们能找到能引起共鸣的粉丝，这对我来说意义重大。
Yeah, keep those voice notes coming in that really is very special.
是的，请继续发来语音消息，那真的非常特别。
And then we just tell you that his name was Sean, he didn't give his name.
然后我们刚要告诉你他的名字叫肖恩，他没有报名字。
Yes, yes, Sean.
对，对，肖恩。
I was going to say it's Sean.
我本来想说是肖恩的。
Thank you, Sean.
谢谢你，肖恩。
Thanks, Sean.
So we're up to episode six in season three.
所以我们讲到了第三季第六集。
This episode is called, I believe I'm not that guy and was written by Jonathan Groff.
这一集名为，如果我没记错的话是《我可不是那家伙》，由乔纳森·格罗夫编剧。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
That is it.
就是这样。
We got it.
我们找到了。
Real great.
真的很棒。
Was he Jonathan Groff came on third season?
他是乔纳森·格罗夫在第三季加入的吗？
Yeah, I should clarify.
对，我应该澄清一下。
This is not the actor Jonathan Groff.
这不是演员乔纳森·格罗夫。
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
Yes.
是的。
The waiter guy.
那个服务生小哥。
Is he dancing?
他在跳舞吗？
Is he right?
是吗？
to how I met your mother episode.
致《老爸老妈浪漫史》的一集。
Well, hyphen it.
好吧，加个连字符。
So this is the writer, Jonathan Groff, who Carter and I very much idolized.
所以这是编剧乔纳森·格罗夫，卡特和我都非常崇拜他。
He was the head writer of Conan O'Brien's old late night show when Carter and I were in college watching every night obsessed with that show, looking at the credits going, I wonder if one day we can get on as writers on that show.
当卡特和我在上大学、每天晚上都痴迷于那个节目时，他是柯南·奥布莱恩的老牌深夜秀的首席编剧，我们看着职员表心想，不知道有一天我们能不能成为那个节目的编剧。
We didn't, we got on Letterman and said, but we, Jonathan Groff was the head writer.
我们没去成，我们去了大卫·莱特曼的节目，但是，乔纳森·格罗夫是首席编剧。
He was like the guy we would have given anything to meet in college.
他就像是我们在大学里愿意付出一切去见的人。
And then years later, he wrote for several seasons on how I met your mother, starting in season three.
然后多年后，他在《老爸老妈浪漫史》中连续担任了多季编剧，从第三季开始。
This is his first episode that he's a credit writer.
这是他署名的第一集。
So he is kind of an idol of ours that eventually worked on our show.
所以他可以说是我们的偶像，最后在我们节目里工作了。
And a great dude.
而且是个超级棒的家伙。
And also I believe a Jeopardy champion.
并且我相信他还是一位《危险边缘》智力竞赛冠军。
Am I wrong about that?
我没记错吧？
A multi-time Jeopardy champion was on there from many days in row one and came back to tournaments of champions and stuff.
多次获得《危险边缘》冠军，连续好几天都在上面，还回过头来参加冠军锦标赛之类的。
Like he killed it on Jeopardy, super smart dude, yeah.
他在《危险边缘》里大杀四方，超级聪明的家伙，对。
I remember it's one of those things.
我记得这是其中一件事。
I remember there's certain geeky things that you're like, I mean, yes, I love that he wrote for Conan, but the fact that he was a Jeopardy.
我记得有些极客的事你会觉得，我是说，是的，我喜欢他为柯南写过剧本，但事实是他曾是《危险边缘》的选手。
Oh my God.
噢天哪。
It was very cool for me.
这对我来说太酷了。
It's very cool.
太酷了。
When I was doing this play, the ally at the public a couple years ago, connections had just started, the word game on the New York Times crossword.
几年前我在公共剧院演那出戏时，《纽约时报》填字游戏里的词汇游戏“连线”刚刚推出。
And the woman who ran that was friends with one of the cast mates in the show, Maddie.
运行那个游戏的女士和剧中的一位演员玛蒂是朋友。
So when she came to the show, we all like surrounded her and wanted a picture with her.
所以她来看演出时，我们都围着她，想和她合影。
And she was so confused.
她当时困惑极了。
She was like, I just saw you in a play.
她就说，我刚看你演了一出戏。
I don't know why you want a picture with me, but we just we love playing connections Even when we were annoyed at it because it's the that purples hard that one But anyway, uh, yes, so jonathan groff Jeopardy champion and great great comedy writer wrote this episode Alec went to this episode air October 29th 2007.
我不知道你为什么想跟我合影，但我们就是很喜欢玩《连线》游戏，哪怕有时候被它气得不行，因为那个紫色类别太难了。不过总之，是的，乔纳森·格罗夫，曾获得《危险边缘》冠军、非常优秀的喜剧编剧，写了这一集。艾利克斯，这一集播出于2007年10月29日。
Oh my god.
我的天呐。
Oh my god solid 19 years ago.
我的天呐，整整19年前。
That's my secret.
这就是我的秘密。
It's troubling It's so crazy.
这太让人感叹了，太疯狂了。
It's really crazy.
真的很疯狂。
Yeah, quick real quick Why don't you tell us, just give us some broad strokes, what it was accepted about, what happens.
对，快说，简单给我们讲讲大概的轮廓，这一集讲的是什么，发生了什么。
Three things happening in this episode, three main kind of like co-stories that kind of all launch from the same thing, Ish.
这一集里有三条主线，三条主要的副线故事，它们基本上都由同一件事引发。
One is this wonderful story where Marshall is just being actively seduced by the great John Cho, who's trying to take, Marshall is about to go, make no money at all, saving the planet, saving the universe at NRDC, but he's getting seduced by this huge corporation, this great sort of study in like, what are your ideals versus the practicality of these newly married, they wanna have kids.
一个是这样一个精彩的故事：马歇尔正面临着由伟大的约翰·赵带来的极大诱惑。约翰·赵试图把马歇尔拉拢过去——马歇尔本来打算去自然资源保护委员会（NRDC）拿极少甚至没有薪水来拯救地球、拯救宇宙，但他却被一家大公司给诱惑了。这是一个很好的探讨：你的理想与现实之间的冲突，尤其是他们刚刚结婚，还想生孩子。
So it's a good study in that.
所以这是一个很好的探讨主题。
I mean, well, Barney has really completely separately.
我是说，呃，巴尼这边其实完全是另一条线。
It is a completely separate storyline.
这是一条完全独立的故事线。
Barney has found a porno movie with an actor named Ted Mosby in it, where with a very featured, it is Ted Mosby in big, bold type on a porno DVD, old tech alert to quote our friends, Angela and Jenna over on office ladies, old tech porn on DVD on porn, DVD porn, and then this is one of my favorite parts.
巴尼发现了一部色情电影，里面有一个演员叫泰德·莫斯比，而且名字非常显眼——“泰德·莫斯比”几个大字赫然印在色情DVD上。这是“旧科技警报”（借用我们办公室女士播客里安吉拉和珍娜的话）：DVD色情片，旧科技色情片，刻在DVD上的色情片。然后，这是我最喜欢的桥段之一。
Lily's little reveal in this episode is actually in some ways the most substantive thing and carries over into the next episode, the reveal that Lily is in massive debt due to a shopping addiction and has not ever told marshal this.
莉莉在这一集里的小秘密揭晓，在某种程度上其实是最具实质性内容的一环，并且一直延续到了下一集：莉莉因为购物成瘾背上了巨额债务，却从来没有告诉过马歇尔。
I really liked the surprise of that reveal.
我真的很喜欢这个谜底揭晓时的惊艳感。
Yeah, and it also, you know, I've said this before but I think that how we met your mother is even though there's bigger apartments, then one would probably be able to get in New York for those salaries, it's pretty honest about the fact that money is a real issue.
对，而且这也，你知道的，我以前也说过，但我认为《老爸老妈浪漫史》——尽管他们的公寓比一般人在纽约拿那种工资所能租到的要大得多——对于“钱是一个现实问题”这一点其实相当诚实。
Money is a thing.
钱是个大问题。
Money is a thing, especially in your 20s.
钱确实是个问题，尤其是在你二十多岁的时候。
These people like, I mean Barney makes money, but no one knows how, but these people like, they don't come from family money.
这些人，我是说巴尼能赚钱，但没人知道他是怎么赚的；不过其他人，他们可不是什么富二代。
They're all trying to do their thing in New York City.
他们都在纽约市努力奋斗。
And I think it's really honest about the fact that, you know, I mean, they might go to the bar because they get like free food, free drinks, you know, they're on a budget, I think, these people.
而且我觉得它很真实的一点是，你知道的，他们去酒吧可能是因为那里有免费的食物和免费的饮料，你知道的，他们手头很紧，我觉得这群人。
Yeah, they're on a, they're on a budget, nobody's rich except maybe Barney, but you don't even really know what he does or whether it's all talk.
对，他们手头很紧，没有人是有钱人，除了巴尼可能算，但你甚至不知道他是干什么的，或者他是不是在吹牛。
But yeah, Marshall, Marshall is in a tight spot.
不过说真的，马歇尔，马歇尔处境艰难。
He's, yeah, he's already being seduced by this huge salary he's being offered.
他，是的，他已经开始被提供的高薪给诱惑了。
And he doesn't even know the part where they're massively in debt and we're not going to find that out until the next episode where I can see Marshall find that out until the next episode.
而且他还不知道他们背负巨额债务的事，直到下一集我们才会看到马歇尔发现这件事。
I like the tension of that.
我很喜欢这种紧张感。
It really is like, I think as a writer, what a thing like to always ask yourself and as early as you can is like, what is their relationship to money?
这真的很像，作为一个编剧，你脑海里总要问自己、而且要尽早问自己的一个问题是：他们和钱的关系是什么？
What is their relationship to their work?
他们和工作关系是什么？
Who are they in the world vis-a-vis resources?
站在资源的立场上，他们在世界上的定位是谁？
And I love that you guys did this.
我很高兴你们这样处理了。
And I think that also, you set up a great, great ethical dilemma for Marshall.
而且我认为，你们也为马歇尔设定了一个非常、非常棒的道德困境。
Yeah.
对。
And he really, really seems sink into the quicksand of that dilemma.
而且他真的、真的仿佛陷入了那个困境的流沙之中。
And it's a very real dilemma.
这是一个非常现实的困境。
Everyone's been in that dilemma where he is.
每个人都经历过他所处的这种困境。
He wants to have four kids.
他想要四个孩子。
Lily wants to, not four, but he really wants to make a living, but he also really wants to save planet Earth.
莉莉想要，虽然不是四个，但他真的很想维持生计，但他同时也真的很想拯救地球。
And it's great.
这太棒了。
It's great to see him torn between those two things.
看到他在这两者之间挣扎非常精彩。
And I really liked the idea and the Simpsons occasionally did this with Marge Simpson, which I also loved.
我很喜欢这个构思——《辛普森一家》偶尔也会在玛姬·辛普森身上这样做，我也很喜欢。
We really made Lily not the voice of reason.
我们真的没有把莉莉塑造成纯粹的理性之声。
Lily often has to be the voice of like, here's what's up.
莉莉通常扮演的是那种“情况是这样的”的角色。
I'm going to shake you out of anyone's being insane.
“我要把你从任何发疯的状态中摇醒。”
I'm going to snap you out of it.
“我要让你清醒过来。”
I'm going to be the person that says this is what it is.
“我要做那个指出事实真相的人。”
And in this one, she's just wrong.
但在这一集里，她就是错的。
She has run up a huge debt.
她欠下了巨额债务。
She's never told Marshall they got married with him not knowing that, I really enjoyed how much she's in the wrong in this one, because she's usually right.
她结婚时瞒着马歇尔这件事，我非常喜欢她在这一集里错得离谱的设定，因为她平时总是对的。
She's usually right.
她通常都是对的。
It's really interesting seeing the right person be wrong.
看那个一贯正确的人犯错真的很有意思。
And the other thing we're trying to acknowledge, which I play as Josh with what you're saying, I think we were pretty honest about money and what I really are at least honest that money would be an issue to these folks.
我们要承认的另一件事是，顺着乔什你的话来说，我觉得我们在金钱方面相当诚实，或者说至少承认金钱对这些人来说是个问题。
But we always talked about this in the writer's room and sometimes even people would ask us, fans would ask us, how can Lilly, a kindergarten public school teacher, afford the amazing wardrobe, that again, a wardrobe department is putting on her on a TV show.
但我们总是在编剧室里讨论这个，有时甚至粉丝也会问我们：“莉莉作为一个公立学校的幼儿园老师，怎么买得起那些惊艳的服装？”——当然，那是电视剧里的服装部门给她搭配的。
And it looks like that.
而且看起来非常时髦。
She got very fashionable season three.
她在第三季变得非常时尚。
She's dressed very fashionably.
她穿得非常时髦。
And we thought, let's acknowledge that, right?
我们就想，不如承认这一点吧？
Fans of friends are always like, how can they be in that huge gigantic mansion apartment that they're in?
《老友记》的粉丝总是会问：他们怎么能住得起那么大、那么巨大的公寓？
I think friends did try to explain that, but we said, this came up enough that we said, let's just do an episode where we acknowledge that no, she cannot afford all these clothes and all these bags and all these boots, she can't.
我觉得《老友记》曾试图解释过，但我们觉得这个问题被问得够多了，于是我们决定拍一集来承认：不，她根本买不起所有这些衣服、所有的包和所有的靴子，她买不起。
And it's a fucking problem.
这他妈是个大问题。
But also, I was reminded, don't they also have wedding debt?
不过话说回来，我突然想起来，他们是不是还有婚礼债务？
Like that, it's not just the shopping debt.
就那种，不只是购物债务。
I wish we'd mentioned that actually, because that doesn't just go away, right?
我真希望我们当时提到了这一点，因为那笔钱不会凭空消失，对吧？
They totally had wedding debt from this dress fiasco and like Marshall got, like we made a point of that in season two and we didn't really tap it.
因为婚纱的闹剧，他们确实留下了婚礼债务，而且马歇尔——我们在第二季里强调过这一点，但之后并没有怎么深入挖掘。
I wish we'd mention it.
我真希望我们当时提到了它。
Let's just say that the wedding dress debt is part of the credit card debt that comes back to haunt her at the next time.
我们就当婚纱欠下的债也是信用卡债务的一部分吧，这会在下一集里继续纠缠她。
I'll say it all adds up in that very clever and we didn't forget to say that.
我会说这一切在那个巧妙的设计中都积聚了起来，我们没有忘记这一点。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小曲，要在纽约市唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed podcast.
嗨，我是艾利克斯·戈德曼，《Hyper-Fixed》播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会倾听听众的烦恼并试着为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：“我30岁了，但不敢在纽约开车。”
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者：“为什么当我挂倒档时，不能调节汽车音响的音量？”
we also solve non-car related problems.
我们也会解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that caused that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么烦恼，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的背后隐藏机制。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的《Hyper-Fixed》播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 找到它。
Like you guys in this episode, you were talking about environmental devastation and porn.
就像你们在这一集里探讨的那样，你们聊到了环境破坏和色情制品。
Two issues that have only swollen, if you have only gotten bigger as the years have gone on.
这两个问题随着时间的推移，只有不断膨胀，变得越来越严重。
So tip of the hat to the prophetic writer's room of how I met your mother.
所以，向《老爸老妈浪漫史》富有先见之明的编剧室致敬。
Yeah, and the idea of selling out the environment to corporate concerns and letting go of these ideals because you're tempted by money like that, that's in the news, that's a thing.
是的，为了企业利益出卖环境，因为抵挡不住金钱的诱惑而放弃理想，这经常出现在新闻里，是现实存在的事。
It's unfortunately.
这很不幸。
And it's also like, I don't know, like, there's something really tender and sweet about watching one's like youthful ideals, like not quite curdle, but just yield to real world metrics, you know?
而且这也是，怎么说呢，看着某人年少时的理想——虽然没有完全变质，但只是向现实世界的功利标准低头——这个过程有一种非常温柔而又酸楚的感觉，你知道吗？
Yeah.
对。
Like, Marshall, I mean, didn't you plant it in flashbacks, he was a little kid and he got like concerned about the environment, right?
就像马歇尔，我的意思是，闪回里不是演过吗？他还是个小男孩的时候就很关心环境，对吧？
Yeah, yeah, life among the gorillas.
对，对，大猩猩的生活。
He had life among the gorillas.
他演过《大猩猩的生活》。
Exactly.
没错。
He's seen good old type woman come visit his school when he was a kid.
他小时候见过亲切的简·古道尔来他的学校参观。
Yeah, and he's a true believer and a real sincere guy around this stuff.
对，他是这方面的坚定信仰者，也是一个非常真诚的人。
But then, you know, it's kind of like, well, I can have this little plot of land that I can grow my family on.
但随后，你知道的，就有点像：“好吧，我可以拥有这一小块土地，用来繁衍我的家庭。”
And what's so wrong with that?
那又有什么错呢？
I do think that you cast exactly the right actors to seduce him because John Cho.
我觉得你们确实选对了演员来诱惑他，因为约翰·赵。
He's so good in this.
他在这一集里演得太好了。
He's really good in this.
他在这一集里真的很棒。
I tell you a John Cho related Hollywood story.
我给你们讲个关于约翰·赵的好莱坞故事。
Please.
请讲。
So do you remember, and I think I've talked about this guy, I've talked about this a lot because it was part of my origin story as a professional actor, my very first audition in LA, I got cast by the white's brothers and Danny Zuker in this show for the WB called Off-Center.
你们还记得吗——我想我可能说过这事，我经常提起它，因为这是我作为职业演员的起点故事——我在洛杉矶的第一次试镜，被怀特兄弟和丹尼·祖克选中，出演华纳兄弟（WB）的一部名为《基情四射》的剧。
It was my first audition in LA in my first room, and I got this part, we shot the pilot.
那是我在洛杉矶的第一次试镜，进的第一个房间，然后我得到了这个角色，我们拍摄了试播集。
I'm waiting.
我在等。
it's gonna go, it's gonna go.
要播了，要播了。
They picked up the pilot and replaced me, fired me, essentially, which is a very common story in Hollywood.
他们选了另一个试播集主演并换掉了我，基本上就是炒了我，这在好莱坞是很常见的事。
It's happened to a lot of people, but in that pilot was a young John Cho.
很多人都经历过，但在那个试播集里有个年轻的约翰·赵。
I forgot that, I knew where you're going with this.
我都忘了，我本来就知道你要说到这儿。
I remember that pilot.
我还记得那个试播集。
Yeah, so I worked with John that whole week or two and he was awesome, he was so great.
对，所以我跟约翰合作了那一整个星期或两周，他太棒了，真的非常棒。
This is all pre-hearled and Kumar, like, you know.
这一切都发生在《寻堡奇遇》之前，你知道的。
but it was when we were, you know, we were all on the pilot circuit together.
但那是我们都在一起跑试播集的时候。
Show was like the guy off American Pie at that point.
当时那家伙就像是《美国派》里的那个演员。
He had a funny little turn in American Pie.
他在《美国派》里有个很有趣的小角色。
I think that was his claim to fame at that moment before all this other big shit, yeah.
我想那可以说是他在经历其他那些大火之前，当时成名的代表作吧。
And they replaced me with Eddie K.
然后他们换上了埃迪·K·
Thomas from American Pie, so it all came first.
托马斯，就是《美国派》里的那个，所以一切都联系上了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, see?
对，对，对，你看？
The deck was stacked against you.
当时的所有牌都对你不利。
No.
不是。
But I mean, it all ended out to be great.
但我的意思是，结果一切都很好。
Like, in a lot of ways, it was a very, how I met your mother-ish kind of thing because it was like, I wanted it to go one way and it went another way.
从很多方面来看，这很像那种《老爸老妈浪漫史》式的经历，因为就好像，我希望事情按一个方向发展，结果却去了另一个方向。
And it ended out to be just the greatest thing for me.
最后证明这对我都不能再好了。
One, it, well, it freed me up for some great work that came along.
第一，它，嗯，它让我腾出时间接了后来出现的一些很棒的工作。
The next season I got on this John Well show with Sally Field called The Court and then I did The Graduate on Broadway.
第二季我参演了萨莉·菲尔德主演的约翰·韦尔斯剧集《法庭》，然后我在百老汇演了《毕业生》。
Like, things just opened up for me after that.
就像，那之后我的机会全打开了。
But it really taught me, I remember my mom saying, go back out to LA.
但这真的教会了我，我记得我妈妈说，回洛杉矶去。
Like, don't act like LA shut the door on your career out there.
别表现得好像洛杉矶对你的职业生涯关上了大门一样。
like go back, get a back up on the horse, you know?
就回去，重新振作起来，你知道吗？
And I did, and here we are.
我照做了，然后我们就坐在这里了。
But it was- I love that story.
但我——我喜欢这个故事。
I never knew your mom was like giving you the pep talk.
我以前不知道你妈妈还给你过这种鼓舞。
Well, she, you know, I was dating this woman at the time and she was gonna go back out there and it was kind of like, I was just hesitant because I felt like really stung, you know?
嗯，她，你知道，我当时在和一个女人交往，她要回那边去，然后就有点像，我当时很犹豫，因为我觉得真的很受打击，你知道吗？
No, it's terrible feeling.
不，那种感觉太糟糕了。
It is a terrible feeling.
这真的是一种糟糕的感觉。
In that moment, that is a fucking terrible feeling.
在那一刻，那他妈的绝对是一种糟糕的感觉。
I'm sorry you went through that.
我很遗憾你经历了那些。
But I found this like new resilience.
但我发现了一种全新的韧性。
Like I found this like, I could take a punch.
就像我发现，我抗击打能力挺强的。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
It is so good for young actors and young anybody listening to that show that I take a punch.
这对年轻演员和听这个节目的任何年轻人来说都太好了，我能承受挫折。
I'm so glad you're talking about this because it does fucking happen.
我很高兴你谈到这一点，因为这种事他妈的确实会发生。
Yeah, it happens a lot.
对，这经常发生。
And your 20s are about like learning how to take a punch in certain way.
你的二十多岁就是要在某种程度上学会如何承受生活的重击。
Yeah, well, we do talk about that on this little TV.
对，没错，我们在我们这个小电视节目里也确实探讨过这个。
And Ted got punched all the time, literally punched.
而且泰德总是挨打，字面意义上的挨打。
Yeah, and Marshall, I mean, in this episode.
对，还有马修，我是说，在这集里。
Wendy, the waitress got a quark in the eye.
女服务员温迪眼里还扎了个软木塞。
Yes, we're gonna get there.
对，我们马上就会聊到那。
That's the next one.
那是下一集。
What Marshall's going through in this episode is he's kind of where you were then.
马修这一集经历的事情，其实就有点像你当时的处境。
Like it's like, who am I?
就像是，我是谁？
I have this dream.
我有这个梦想。
I'm going to try to do my dream, but how can I really build a career of this?
我要去实现我的梦想，但我怎么才能真正靠这个建立职业生涯呢？
Like you were right in like one of these existential pockets and Marshall, like it actually does.
就像你当时正处于这种存在主义的困境中一样，马修，实际上确实如此。
This episode's kind of about that, that moment anyway.
总之这一集差不多就是关于那个时刻的。
Well, it's also like your 20s, I know that how I met your mother is like considered a romantic comedy and it's so much of the idea of it is like, who am I gonna end up with, right?
好吧，这其实也关乎你的二十多岁，我知道《老爸老妈浪漫史》被认为是一部浪漫喜剧，它的很多核心概念是——我最后会和谁在一起，对吧？
Like that's the central mystery.
就像那是核心谜团。
Who's he gonna end up with?
他最后会和谁在一起？
But that's not the only question that you're asking yourself from the age of 27 to 35 or six.
但从27岁到35、36岁，你问自己的绝不仅仅只有这一个问题。
Like you're also saying, who am I vis-a-vis my career?
你同时也在问，就我的职业生涯而言，我是谁？
What kind of mark do I wanna make?
我想留下什么样的印记？
You know, what am I contributing to the world?
你知道，我对这个世界有什么贡献？
Or what am I, you know, what compromises am I making to live my dreams, and am I even still living my dreams?
或者我，你知道，为了实现梦想我做出了什么妥协，而且我甚至还在过着我的梦想生活吗？
Is that a youthful idea, living your dreams, you know?
过着梦想的生活，这是一个只属于年轻人的想法吗，你知道的？
Yeah, well, Marshall, this is it.
对，好吧，马修，就是这样。
Or am I gonna stick to my dreams or am I gonna make money?
或者我是该坚持梦想还是去赚钱？
I just got married, I'm actually really glad.
我刚结完婚，我其实真的很高兴。
I was up to this episode, what is this, is 306.
直到这一集，这是第几集，这是3季06集。
I have felt like a little bit from 301 to 305.
从3季01集到3季05集，我一直觉得有点。
We've dropped the idea that they just got married a little bit.
我们有点淡化了他们刚结婚这个设定。
They're just living with Ted.
他们只是和泰德住在一起。
We're not really talking about the fact that a married couple's living with Ted.
我们并没有怎么讨论一对新婚夫妇和泰德住在一起的事实。
We don't even mention that really.
我们甚至都没有真正提起过。
Are they thinking about moving in the next episode, which is Doh Isopriplo, we get to that.
他们是不是在考虑在下一集搬走，也就是《Doh Isopriplo》那一集，我们会聊到那。
I really like these two episodes for Marshall and Lily, because it reminds you, they did just get married.
我真的很喜欢马修和莉莉的这两集，因为这提醒了你，他们确实刚结婚。
They are looking at the future.
他们正在展望未来。
They're, what is his career gonna be?
他们在想，他的职业会是什么样的？
What is their family gonna be?
他们的家庭会是什么样的？
How are they gonna make money?
他们要怎么赚钱？
The next episode really does get right to, can we really live with a single dude as a married couple?
下一集确实直接切入了核心：作为一对新婚夫妇，我们真的能和一个单身汉住在一起吗？
Is this really, is this okay?
这真的、这样可以吗？
Does this work?
这行得通吗？
And I like these two episodes for that, because I would argue it's been a little bit like radio silence on the fact that they have a completely different life chapter starting.
我很喜欢这两集的这一点，因为我想说，在此之前，对于他们即将开启完全不同的人生篇章这件事，节目里简直就像无线电静默一样绝口不提。
And, but the first few episodes just weren't about that.
而且，但前几集讲的确实不是这个。
We were talking about other stuff.
我们在聊别的事情。
Well, I'm also though pretty, the more we go through this.
不过，我也觉得挺明显的，我们越往后看。
Yeah.
对。
The more I see the kind of like weird game of Twister Jenga you guys were playing, like it's so intense the amount of balls that are in the air.
我就越能看出你们当时玩的那种奇怪的叠叠乐加层层叠游戏，天呐，同时要兼顾的线索真的太密集了。
Yes, yes.
没错，没错。
You know, plot and character wise.
你知道，无论是剧情还是角色方面。
Yes.
没错。
And I think you do, you thread so much more throughout the series than most shows like this do.
我觉得相比大多数同类剧集，你们在整部剧里串联了更多的细节。
Yeah.
对。
A lot of shows like this really do press reset at the top of every episode.
很多像这样的剧集在每集开场时真的都会按下重置键。
And it's just- Every week is sort of kind of- And you have to shake the edge of sketch, yeah.
然后就是——每周都差不多是一种——而且你还得抖掉素描喜剧的影子，对吧。
And I don't like it when we do that.
而且我不喜欢我们那样做。
I think the show is far better when you're really remembering life continued between from Monday to Monday when the show aired, stuff was happening in these people's lives that added up to something.
我认为这部剧好得多的一点是，你真的会记得当剧集开播时，生活从周一到周一在继续，这些人的生活中确实在发生事情，并且汇聚成了某种意义。
It wasn't like off camera.
那可不是在镜头之外。
Things were still happening.
事情依然在发生。
Yeah.
对啊。
And it's almost, it's a little like, you remember when we talked about the three decisions, hats, haircuts, and tattoos?
这就有点像，你还记得我们讨论过的三个决定吗？发型、帽子和纹身？
Yeah, I love that.
对，我超喜欢那个。
Right, like Lily's debt is becoming like a bit of a tattoo, right?
没错，就像莉莉的债务开始变得有点像纹身了，对吧？
Like she's like, this is becoming more consequential than something I can just unwind with either time or trying on another hat.
就好像这变得比我随便花点时间或换顶帽子就能解决的事情要严重得多。
Or she would probably be like, I want more hats.
或者她可能会觉得：我想要更多帽子。
Yeah, that's your problem.
对，这就是你的问题所在。
And you know, Ted is having like a bit of a like, it's a little bit of a haircut because it's like, there's a tail.
你知道的，泰德也遇到了点情况，有点像是个发型问题，因为这就像是留下了个尾巴。
You know, I mean, it's not the decision of his.
你知道我的意思，这不是他自己作出的决定。
It's like something that was thrust upon him.
这就像是强加在他身上的事情。
But- Good use of thrust.
不过——“强加”这个词用得好。
Good time.
时机正好。
I really, I really do think the, when he thought Architecture Vision Weekly was calling.
我真的、真的觉得，当他以为是《建筑愿景周刊》打来电话的时候……
Oh, that was funny.
哦，那太搞笑了。
That was one of those like kids in a candy store like, okay, what can we say that applies to both architecture vision weekly and adult video monthly.
那种感觉就像糖果店里的小孩一样，心想：“好吧，我们能说点什么，既适用于《建筑愿景周刊》又适用于《成人视频月刊》呢？”
That's where you're like calling Chris Harris.
这就好比你在给克里斯·哈里斯打电话。
Yeah, no, Groff had a field day with that too.
对，没错，格罗夫对那个也驾轻就熟。
Groff is a very smart writer.
格罗夫是个非常聪明的编剧。
He loves the double meanings.
他很喜欢双关语。
Lot of good, very, very funny touches like that from Groff.
格罗夫写了很多这样绝妙、非常非常有趣的细节。
Yeah, hilarious.
对，太爆笑了。
I liked Ted's storyline because it came from this good deed Ted did a long time ago, even though they sort of rewrite history and convince this well-meaning, but I guess slightly dim fellow who's now a porn actor.
我挺喜欢泰德这条故事线的，因为它源于泰德很久以前做好事的一桩善举，尽管他们有点像是在改写历史，并说服了这个好心但现在看来有点糊涂、如今成了色情演员的家伙。
That wasn't me.
那可不是我。
There was this other guy, Lance Hardwood, but Clem Ted did help this guy a long time ago, and the guy actually was trying to tribute Ted, I'll be in a very disturbing time.
那是另一个人，兰斯·哈德伍德，不过克莱姆……泰德确实在很久以前帮过这家伙，而且这家伙其实是想向泰德致敬，尽管是在一个非常诡异的时期。
Did if I make a name for myself.
好让我自己也出名。
He thought it was his way of thinking Ted.
他觉得这是他感谢泰德的方式。
I had like forgotten that that was sort of like, sweet at its core, like weird, strangely sweet.
我差点都忘了，那段情节本质上其实挺温馨的，虽然有点怪，透着一种诡异的温馨。
That guy was also perfectly cast.
那个演员选得也堪称完美。
Kevin Halfernan from the Broken Lizard comedy group, he's in Super Troopers.
喜剧组合“断头蜥蜴”的凯文·赫夫纳恩，他演过《超级骑警》。
He has a big, crazy mustache in Super Troopers.
他在《超级骑警》里留着一把又大又疯狂的胡子。他在那部电影里搞笑极了。
He's hilarious in the movie.
他在那部电影里搞笑极了。
He was so funny and open and sincere.
他表现得那么滑稽、坦诚又真挚。
I thought he just really got it right.
我觉得他真的把这个角色演到位了。
He was really sweet.
他真的很可爱。
That's what I mean.
这就是我的意思。
I was like, taking it back.
我当时就想，这把我给整不会了。
I was like, this is so sweet.
我当时想：这太温馨了吧。
I mean, he's fucking people as Ted Mosby, but it's weirdly sweet.
我是说，他在跟别人上床时用的是泰德·莫斯比的名字，但这诡异地透着温馨。
He sort of, well, that's another thing.
他有点像——哦，还有一件事。
It's like, this show probably for a multi-camera sitcom talked about porn more than any other, right?
就是说，这部剧作为一部多镜头情景喜剧，谈论色情话题的频率大概比其他任何剧都高吧？
Not to brag.
倒也不是在自吹自擂。
But again, almost like with the threesome episode, It's like, how are you making this thing so sweet?
但话说回来，就像三人行那一集一样，你会想：你们是怎么把这种事拍得这么温馨的？
Yeah, it wasn't that gross.
对，其实没那么恶心。
It was a kind of like, it was well-intentioned.
它有种……而且发心是好的。
Like, if you're gonna do a porn story, like, what's the beating heart beneath the porn?
就像，如果你要拍一个关于色情的故事，那么，色情背后的核心动力是什么？
And it also is like, you think, like, oh, talking to this porn actor, like, what's his big trauma?
而且你也会想，哦，跟这个色情演员对话，他有什么巨大的心理创伤吗？
Well, he was picked on as a kid, but Ted saved him.
好吧，他小时候被人欺负过，但泰德救了他。
And he just kind of went into porn the way one would go into any other thing.
然后他进入色情行业，就像人们从事任何其他行业一样自然。
It's like in Ratatouille where you go and set the critic and see that he was just a little sad kid You want him to eat ratatouille?
就像在《料理鼠王》里，你去看那位美食评论家，发现他其实也只是个曾经有点伤心的小男孩，你只想让他吃上一口普罗旺斯炖菜？
It's like, oh, this porn actor, he just was a sad lost boy.
这就好比：哦，这个色情演员，他以前只是个伤心、迷失的小男孩。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
But Marshall also, like, he's going through a thing.
但马修也是，他正在经历一些事情。
It's almost like, you know, when, like, there's a fresh snow, and you can make fresh tracks?
这感觉就像，你知道的，当刚下过一场新雪，你可以踩出新鲜的足迹时那种感觉？
Like, that's what, like, leaving college feels like.
离开大学大概就是这种感觉。
But the more you ski in the tracks, they get iced in, the grooves get in, right?
但你在这些脚印里滑得越多，它们就会结冰，车辙就会定型，对吧？
And it's almost like in this episode, like not with Ted as much, but Lily and Marshall are really like, we know that these things are gonna get a little more set and frozen and like, who do we wanna be?
几乎就像在这集里——虽然泰德没那么明显——但莉莉和马修真的在想：我们知道这些事情会变得更加固定和僵化，那么，我们到底想成为什么样的人？
Where do we wanna live?
我们想住在哪里？
What kind of work do we wanna do?
我们想做哪种工作？
What compromises are we willing to make?
我们愿意做出什么样的妥协？
These are really big questions.
这些都是非常宏大的问题。
Big questions.
宏大的问题。
And I know that it's a multi-camera to come with a laugh track, but like, I really admire that you guys were not afraid to take some of this stuff on.
我知道这是一部带罐头笑声的多镜头情景喜剧，但我真的很佩服你们敢于探讨这些内容。
Well, thank you, I, what else are you gonna write about, right?
谢谢，我……还能写点什么呢，对吧？
Like you wanted, you wanted to show these people evolving.
就像你想展现这群人的成长一样。
Like you're still growing up, this show is really, we pitch a show as it's how you're still growing up in your late 20s.
就像你还在长大，这部剧其实……我们推销这部剧时的概念就是，它讲的是你快三十岁时如何还在继续成长。
The first few seasons are that, who am I?
前几季讲的就是这些：我是谁？
Literally, who am I?
字面意义上的“我是谁？”。
And the thing I love about Lily in this episode is she's wrong.
而这一集里我最喜欢莉莉的一点是，她大错特错了。
She's like, she's nefarious in her wrongness.
她错得简直离谱。
She is pushing Marshall the wrong way.
她把马修往错误的道路上推。
She's actually to the devil.
她简直就像个魔鬼。
Lady Macbeth in this episode.
她在这一集里就像麦克白夫人。
She's living with this huge guilds.
她背负着巨大的内疚感在生活。
She's like living with this guild.
她带着这种负罪感生活。
She's pushing him.
她在推着他往前走。
Yeah, she's like this whisper of like, when we flashback and we see why she was saying, what she was saying.
对，她就像那种低语——当我们闪回看到她为什么要说那些话的时候。
I kind of forgot that we did that move.
我差点都忘了我们安排了这一出。
I'm very rewatching it.
重看的时候我感触很深。
I hadn't seen this one a long time.
我已经很久没看过这一集了。
It's like, right.
就觉得，没错。
Oh shit.
哦操。
Lily was like, this was like, she was a malicious actor in this one.
莉莉在这集里就像个心怀恶意的作恶者。
She was like not doing what was best for Marshall.
她做的事根本不是为了马修好。
And I loved that for her because so much of the time she is the voice of reason.
我很喜欢她这样，因为在大多数时候她都是理性的化身。
Well, it's almost like the flip of when Barney gets to be like save the day as a little kind of hero because that's not his mode.
嗯，这几乎就像是反转，就像巴尼偶尔能当一次拯救世界的英雄那样，因为那根本不是他的常规人设。
And Lily is so often the conscience of the group that it's really fun to get.
而莉莉通常是团队里的良心，所以能看到这种反转真的很有趣。
And I bet you Allie loved playing that.
我敢打赌艾丽演得一定过瘾极了。
Like, actors love it when you give them like something like a little mustache twirl evil and kind of.
演员都很喜欢你给他们安排那种带点反派特质、捻着胡须使坏的角色。
She's a little yago in this.
她在这里就像个小伊阿古。
She has a little bit of like, she's whispering in his ear like, no, no, go, why not get a free meal out of this?
她有点像是在他耳边低语：不，不，去吧，为什么不顺便白吃一顿呢？
Like, that's her trying to make sure that he gets seduced.
这就是她在试着确保他被诱惑。
She wants him to be seduced to erase her terrible, like, shame and secret that she has, which is really an interesting look for our voice of reason on the show.
她希望他经受诱惑，好以此来抹去她那可怕的羞耻感和秘密，对于我们剧中的理性化身来说，这真是一个很有趣的人物侧面。
I really like seeing that.
我真的很喜欢看这个。
That was my favorite part of this episode in Rewatch.
重看这一集时，这就是我最喜欢的片段。
I was like, I thought that was really strong and weird and it doesn't get resolved in this episode, which I also like, you have to tune in next week, to tune into Melissa Treepla and see how this plays out and it does play out and that one will get there.
我当时想：我觉得这部分处理得非常有张力、很怪异，而且在这集里并没有得到解决，我也很喜欢这一点——你得锁定下周的节目，看看梅丽莎·特里普拉这事到底会怎么发展，它确实有后续，那一集我们会聊到。
You know what is a thing that John Cho's performance reminded me of?
你知道约翰·赵的表演让我想起了什么吗？
I remember someone telling me years ago that if you go see like a C minus agent they'll keep you waiting for two hours but if you go to CAA they'll be early to the meeting and they'll be incredibly charming and and they'll have all the time in the world for you and all the snacks and all the, like there's no, they're so powerful, they don't need to prove their power.
我记得多年前有人告诉我，如果你去找一个水平勉强及格的经纪人，他们会让你等上两个小时；但如果你去CAA（美国艺人经纪公司），他们不仅会在会面时提前到场，而且会极其迷人、有求必应，并且有全世界的时间陪你，还会准备好各种零食，完全没有那种架子——他们实力太强了，根本不需要证明自己的实力。
Right.
没错。
Whereas someone with less power is more insecure about it, so they're trying to kind of prove their power.
而那些实力较弱的人则对此更加缺乏安全感，所以他们会极力去证明自己的实力。
And Joe, I just think, plays that probably, like the way he just sits on the desk and how everything is like, no big deal.
而我认为，乔对角色的处理大概也是这样，比如他随意地坐在桌子上，把一切都处理得云淡风轻。
No big deal, man.
没关系，老兄。
I know you're not taking this job.
我知道你不会接这份工作。
Let's just go run up some money.
我们去捞点钱吧。
Let's just charge money on him.
我们就从他身上搞点钱。
Yeah, it's hilarious.
对，太搞笑了。
He's great.
他太棒了。
And he goes right to the place of his vulnerability confusion.
而且他直奔自己脆弱和迷茫的地方。
Like he knows he sees it, you know?
就像他知道并能看清那样，你知道吗？
Yeah, he's really masterful.
对，他真的很老练。
It's such a it's a well written character and it's perfectly played.
这是一个写得极好的角色，而且演得完美无瑕。
Everyone, this is Alec stepping in for a moment.
各位，我是亚历克，插播几句。
We had hoped to speak with John Cho about this episode, but our schedules didn't align until they did.
我们本希望就这一集采访约翰·赵，但我们的档期一直没对上，直到现在才对上。
He was able to join us just a little while after we had recorded the episode you're listening to now.
就在我们录完你现在正在听的这一集之后不久，他加入了我们。
And while we thought we would just catch up for a few minutes, Josh, Craig and John will end up talking for more than half an hour.
本以为我们只是随便聊上几分钟，但乔什、克雷格和约翰最后聊了半个多小时。
You can hear the full interview in a bonus episode dropping later this week.
你可以在本周晚些时候发布的特别节目中收听完整的采访。
For now, here's just a small excerpt of our talk with John Cho, who played the deliciously evil Jefferson Coatesworth.
现在，这只是我们与约翰·赵访谈的一小段精彩节选，他在剧中饰演了那个坏得迷人的杰斐逊·科茨沃思。
I did rewatch it.
我确实重看了一遍。
And I was like, one, I was like, this is such sharp writing.
当时我就觉得，第一，这台词写得太犀利了。
There's so many joke handles all the time.
到处都有那么多包袱梗。
She's like, okay.
她就像是，好吧。
And there's so many joke rums to hang on to at each corner.
而且每个转角都有那么多梗可以抓得住。
It's very dense, it's very joke.
信息量很大，满是笑料。
I think the way I'm saying it, there's joke right.
我觉得我这么说吧，里面确实有很多梗，对吧。
That's sort of like, you felt like there was so many to grab onto with each line.
就好像你觉得每一句台词都有那么多东西可以抓取。
I can see you doing that because you just so nail each line and each line has its own take and journey in the way that you do it.
我能理解你这么做，因为你把每一句台词都拿捏得死死的，而且以你的方式，每一句台词都有它自己的视角和心路历程。
And I like getting a peek in your brain of how that's how you see it.
我很喜欢窥探你的大脑，看看你是怎么看待这一点的。
You know, I got the feeling, because I wasn't, it's so weird, because I don't have a strong memory of John being on set.
你知道的，我有这种感觉，因为我没有……这太奇怪了，因为我对约翰在片场没什么深刻的记忆。
I was like, we didn't have any scenes together, that's why.
我就想，我们没有对手戏，这就是原因。
We didn't have scenes together, that's why.
我们没有对手戏，所以才这样。
Yeah, I found it.
对，我发现了。
But I got the feeling like you were really enjoying the mix of getting to be both charming and evil seemed like something you were enjoying playing.
但我总觉得你真的很享受那种既迷人又邪恶的混合状态，演起来似乎让你乐在其中。
I do like that, okay.
我确实很喜欢那个，好吧。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
It's a good one, man.
这很棒，老兄。
It's a good one.
这真的很棒。
I do enjoy being a douche.
我确实很享受当个混蛋。
Yeah.
对。
Well, sometimes I feel like you and I have both been asked to be like the virtuous center of things.
嗯，有时候我觉得你和我都曾被要求扮演各种事情中正直的核心。
And then when you get to be on the side and be like a little more yago or a little more crazy.
然后当你站在旁边，变得更像伊阿古或者更疯狂一点的时候。
It's fun.
这很有趣。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Is Iago, that's a character from Jeff Fox, who had the show.
是伊阿古吗，那是杰夫·福克斯的剧里的角色。
Yeah.
对。
He was the breakout.
他是最出彩的那个。
Yeah, I remember him.
对，我记得他。
And everyone was like, everyone wants to be Iago.
每个人都觉得，人人都想演伊阿古。
I do like that.
我确实很喜欢那样。
I was going to the, I think also the density, may I propose a theory?
我要去……我觉得还有密集度，我可以提出一个理论吗？
Please.
请说。
We love theories here.
我们这里最喜欢各种理论了。
I didn't know, I don't know why I didn't know, I didn't know you guys didn't use a studio audience.
我不知道，我怎么会不知道，我不知道你们不用现场观众。
Oh, like you, did you show up to the experience thinking this isn't, this, there's going to be a good people.
哦，就像你，你来的时候以为这不是……这里会有一群好观众吗？
Well, I look at the bleachers.
嗯，我看了看看台。
Yes, that's what I'd come from.
对，我是从那种环境出来的。
And I was like, oh, they don't do this.
然后我就想，哦，他们不搞这个。
And I, and I think I was thirsty for laughs from the studio audience.
而且我，我觉得我很渴望现场观众的笑声。
And it was, and in some ways, like, I was, after I did, you know, Josh, I did the year on the sitcom, and I came off of that going, I shouldn't do these anymore.
而且，在某种程度上，就像我做完之后，你知道的，乔什，我拍了一年情景喜剧，拍完之后我就想，我不该再拍这些了。
I don't think it's good for me because I was such a flower.
我觉得这对没好处，因为我当时太像向日葵了。
Yes, this is our theory that we share this theory.
对，这就是我们的理论，我们都有同感。
I was bending towards the light all the time.
我一直在向光弯曲。
It warps your performance in a lot of ways.
这在很多方面会扭曲你的表演。
It cranks you up, and you're trying to get laughter from people that they're tossing candy to.
它会让你亢奋，而你试图从那些把糖果抛给他们的人那里博取笑声。
Yes.
是的。
And it's just, and we always thought like you, you do the run through for the crew.
而且这只是……我们总觉得像你一样，你为剧组排练过。
The crew really laughs the first time you do it, but the cameras aren't rolling, right?
你第一次演的时候剧组真的笑得很开心，但摄像机没在转，对吧？
So then once the cameras start rolling, you just have to depend on your own sense of like comedy, but also truth.
所以一旦摄像机开始拍摄，你只能依靠自己对喜剧的直觉，还有真实感。
And I think it kept us like more subtle and more grounded, even though they would pipe in laughter.
我觉得这让我们保持得更含蓄、更扎实，尽管他们会塞进罐头笑声。
I agree.
我同意。
And then really to the density comment, I feel like you could layer in more because you could keep it in rhythm.
然后说到刚才密度的那个评论，我觉得你可以加入更多层次，因为你可以保持节奏。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Instead of like being busted up by the laughs.
而不是像被笑声打断那样。
And that's the thing about the studio audience too.
这也是现场观众的问题所在。
It's like, you want the laughs and it feels great to get a laugh.
就像，你想要笑声，得到笑声感觉很棒。
And then you do, on the third take, they go, oh, that didn't get as much of a laugh.
然后你在第三条时，他们会说，哦，那个没引来那么多笑声。
We should rewrite the joke.
我们应该重写这个笑话。
And then people huddle up and they try and beat the joke.
然后大家聚在一起，试图想出更好的笑话。
And I was like, I guess that made sense at the time, but looking back, I'm like, it did work.
当时我心想，这在当时可能说得通，但现在回想起来，我觉得它本来挺管用的。
I know, it doesn't really make sense.
我懂，这其实说不通。
It doesn't really make sense.
这其实根本说不通。
It's like, you might get another decent joke, but it doesn't mean the one that they heard for the third time it didn't laugh is now bad.
这就好像，你可能会得到另一个不错的笑话，但这并不意味着他们听了第三遍没笑的那个现在就变成烂梗了。
It's just, it is a weird brain thing that happens.
这只是，大脑产生的一种奇怪机制。
The alternate joke is typically not as on story.
备用笑话通常没那么贴合剧情。
It felt like, I know it's real, but it's not.
感觉就像，我知道它是真实的，但又不是。
It's just to, it's a freestanding joke.
它只是一个独立的笑话。
It drops the audience back to life.
它把观众重新带回了现实。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's right.
对，对，对，对，对，没错。
That's a good way to put it, Josh.
乔什，你这话总结得真好。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, new York City.
这个老头，他……我爱上了你，纽约市。
And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
现在是广告时间，广告结束，回到节目。
I love that we got a fucking Ferris wheel.
我很高兴我们弄到了一台该死的摩天轮。
That's a big deal shoot.
那可是一场大制作的拍摄。
I think we shot that just somewhere in the Fox lot because all you really see is like trees behind it.
我觉得我们只是在福克斯外景地的某处拍的，因为你真正能看到的只有它背后的树。
I think we just we didn't go on location somewhere to that.
我觉得我们当时没有去什么外景地拍那个。
I think we brought in a Ferris wheel to the Fox lot.
我觉得我们是把一台摩天轮搬到了福克斯外景地。
I'm almost positive.
我几乎可以肯定。
I should have asked Pam before this.
我应该在采访前问问帕姆的。
It's a great shot when he I think he offers him like it's something and you just see Marshall and then you the Ferris wheel goes down.
那是一个很棒的镜头，当他——我觉得他递给对方某种东西，然后你只看到马歇尔，接着摩天轮就下去了。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
It's such a great.
真是太棒了。
It's a great moment.
这真是一个精彩的时刻。
Yeah.
对。
But you never really see anything around that first wheel and I think we were just on like somewhere next to the parking lot at the Fox.
但你其实根本看不到摩天轮周围有什么，我觉得我们当时大概就在福克斯片场停车场旁边的地方。
When you when you are able to cheat effectively, film and TV, that's a really good cheat.
当你能有效地进行“作弊”时，在电影和电视里，这真是一个很棒的“作弊”。
You know, you didn't go to the amusement park.
你知道的，你们根本没去游乐园。
Yeah.
对。
That is a really good cheat.
这真的是个绝妙的障眼法。
hang on.
等等。
Let's just see if it happens.
我们来看看这事是不是真的。
I'm going to see.
我来看看。
She often gets back to us quickly.
她通常很快就会回复我们。
Didn't we shoot that on?
我们当年不是在那儿拍的吗？
I'm almost positive.
我几乎可以肯定。
We just found some little tree on the fox slide and said, you'll see a little bit of that tree.
我们只是在福克斯外景地随便找了棵小树，然后说，你会看到那棵树的一小部分。
We will never shoot wide.
我们绝不会拍全景。
Yeah.
对。
And it's also fun to think like, you know, when when you look at stage 22 and it was like all the the movies that were shot.
而且一想到这个也很有趣，你知道的，当你看看22号摄影棚，以前有多少电影都在那儿拍过。
I think nine to five was shot on stage 22.
我觉得《朝九晚五》就是在22号摄影棚拍的。
And it was, yeah, for sure.
那是肯定的。
Oh, Pam wrote back?
哦，帕姆回信了？
Yes, she thinks, yeah.
对，她觉得是的。
It was on the Fox lot on the first meal.
就是在福克斯片场的摩天轮那儿拍的。
And it was like next to a parking structure or something.
而且好像就在停车场建筑或者什么东西旁边。
And we really liked it.
我们真的很喜欢。
Pam also, like, I told her recently, like, an episode, we had, it was a beginning of season three episode.
而且帕姆，就像我最近告诉她的那样，有一集，那是第三季刚开始的一集。
And I was telling her how much fun I have watching it.
我当时告诉她我看这一集觉得多有意思。
And she's like, I remember every moment of that episode.
然后她说：“那一集的每一个瞬间我都记得。”
Like, I think Pam is like a walking oral history of this show.
我觉得帕姆就像这部剧的活口述历史一样。
Yeah, she really, she was there for every moment.
对，真的，她经历每一个时刻。
She had to figure out where do you put a ferris wheel on the Fox lot that doesn't, that we can shoot and then get a little context.
她得琢磨在福克斯片场的哪儿能放个摩天轮，既能拍摄，又能拍出一点环境背景。
I remember there's just a tree.
我记得就只有一棵树。
You see like a tree in mine.
你画面里能看到一棵树。
So yeah, anyway, that was just right, probably near our stage on the Fox lot.
所以，总之，那大概就正好在我们福克斯片场的摄影棚附近。
It looked like we went to an amusement park where we definitely did not.
看起来我们去了游乐园，而我们绝对没去。
So let's go through and just, I'm just gonna say, I like to do this, just the things I wrote down that really landed on me, I thought were funny.
所以我们接下来，我就直说了——我喜欢这么干，就是把我记下来、真正触动我、我觉得很有趣的那些点过一遍。
Marshall gives a great Michael Shea guys, guys, guys, at the start of the episode.
马歇尔在剧集开头模仿迈克尔·谢（Michael Shea）的“伙计们，伙计们，伙计们”模仿得太棒了。
couple guys, guys, guys, the reference to our system director, Michael Shea, who would say guys, guys, guys, to round up the cast and a cast replaced.
好几个“伙计们，伙计们，伙计们”，这是在致敬我们的助理导演迈克尔·谢，他以前经常喊“伙计们，伙计们，伙计们”来把演员们集合到片场。
Anytime guys was in the script, they made a guys, guys, guys, as a tribute to Michael Shea, he's always barking at them.
只要剧本里出现“伙计们”，他们就会喊“伙计们，伙计们，伙计们”来致敬迈克尔·谢，他总是对他们大吼大叫。
That's the backstory for the casual, how we know how we d-banged him, how we how we made it.
这就是这个梗的幕后故事，我们是怎么知道的，我们是怎么恶搞他的，我们是怎么做出来的。
We took away his power.
我们剥夺了他的权力。
I believe there are two of those in this episode, by the way.
顺便说一句，我觉得这一集里有两次这个梗。
I know two guys, guys, guys, guys.
我知道，两次“伙计们，伙计们，伙计们”。
I liked when Kobe said, I know what kind of plane this is.
我喜欢科比（Kobe）说的那句：“我知道这是什么飞机。”
It's a boing.
“这是一架波音（Boing）。”
That feels like a That feels like a graph joke.
感觉这就像是一个……感觉这就像是个格罗斯（Graph）式的笑话。
Yeah.
对。
The making Ted make the face to see if he looks like him.
让泰德（Ted）做鬼脸，看看他长得像不像他。
And that was really funny.
那真的超级搞笑。
OK, you know what really made me and Jordana laugh?
好吧，你知道有什么真正让我和乔丹娜笑喷了吗？
Is the Jude law run that Kobe goes on?
就是科比模仿裘德·洛的那段跑步吗？
Oh, my God.
噢，天哪。
She just runs out of steam in this phenomenal way.
她那种强弩之末的状态演得太绝了。
And then Ted going shh, shh, just the gentle.
然后是泰德发出嘘、嘘的声音，就那么温和地。
It is such it is so shameful.
真的是太丢脸了。
My kids do that to me.
我的孩子们也会对我那样。
And sometimes Rebecca, they'll go just stop.
有时候丽贝卡，他们会说，别说了。
That's it's so it's so shameful.
那真的、真的太丢脸了。
It's so effective.
但又太管用了。
It's just such a funny thing when you think you got a good joke.
当你以为自己讲了个好笑的笑话时，那种情况真的太逗了。
Yeah.
是啊。
No one's quite getting doesn't land.
根本没人get到，笑话没响。
And you just dig yourself a deeper and deeper hole with it.
然后你只能用它让自己越陷越深。
Or you say, did you guys hear?
或者你说，你们听到没？
Yeah, no, we heard you.
对，没错，我们听到了。
We just didn't laugh at it.
我们只是觉得不好笑而已。
I love that in her shitty fun break.
我超喜欢她在她那个糟糕的欢聚时刻里的表现。
She's like, I mean, maybe not so much now, but like a couple of years ago to give it some context.
她说，我是说，也许现在不这样了，但大概几年前吧，为了说明一下背景。
She's trying to contextualize it.
她试图给它加上语境。
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
Now it will be funny.
这下可好笑了。
Man, this will save it.
天哪，这能把场子救回来。
She played that so funny.
她把那段演得太搞笑了。
You guys would every once in a while give Robin one of those like, like, she just trying to be like a real comedian.
你们偶尔会给罗宾那种眼神，就像，她只是想学得像个真正的喜剧演员。
Yeah, yeah, totally.
对，对，完全是。
She's so funny.
她太逗了。
Yeah, the architecture vision weekly run was so fun.
对，《建筑视角周刊》的那段太好玩了。
Oh my god.
噢，天哪。
The introduction of John is riding guys.
介绍约翰登场时说的是“骑马的人”。
Yeah.
对。
Oh, now this is a scoop.
噢，这下可是个独家猛料。
Right.
对啊。
And then what he said.
然后他说的话。
Um, I love, you know, it's funny when he calls up and he's like, it has like, I've been reading that since I was a kid.
嗯，我喜欢，你知道最好笑的是他打电话过去说，就好像，我从小就开始看那本杂志了。
The guy's like, well, that's a bummer.
那家伙说，好吧，那可真够遗憾的。
That was a great guest actor read.
那位客串演员的台词念得真棒。
Well, that's a rumor anyway.
好吧，反正那也只是个传言。
But even in the in the heart of like, he clearly does this for a living.
但即使在那种核心时刻，他显然是以此为生的。
Yeah.
对。
But the fact that he's that little kid is a bummer.
但那个小男孩觉得“真遗憾”这个事实。
Yeah.
对。
That's sad.
这太悲哀了。
That's sad for you.
这对你来说很悲哀。
It's sad for me and I'm an adult.
对我来说也很悲哀，而我都已经是成年人了。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
That's good.
真不错。
Oh, good.
哦，太好了。
When John Show is introduced and they show the flashback, getting correct, or leaving.
当约翰·肖登场并播放闪回画面时，简直大快人心，或者是离场。
I loved the spoiler.
我很喜欢这个剧透。
Just by the way, he's fucking evil.
顺便说一句，他他妈的就是个恶魔。
Here's his perp walk.
这是他被押送游街的画面。
Here's funny of his perp walk.
这是他押送画面中搞笑的部分。
And you know that immediately.
而且你马上就能看出来。
And then you just go back and watch the rest of the episode.
然后你就可以回去看这集的剩余部分。
Watch him be charming and it's fine.
看他展现迷人魅力，也没问题。
But what he says is, you could all go to hell.
但他所说的是，你们都见鬼去吧。
I do it again.
我再来一次。
I'm innocent.
我是无辜的。
Yes.
没错。
Every single thing is a different take.
每一个细节都是不同的拍摄版本。
different take, which, you know, we do hear that nowadays.
不同的拍法，你知道，我们现在经常听到这个词。
Oh, my God.
哦，天哪。
Different takes.
不同的版本。
Well, he's, I mean, yeah, he's like, he's got the Trumpy playbook.
嗯，他，我的意思是，是的，他就像，他有特朗普式的套路。
But it was a little Trumpy to say all three things.
但把这三点都说出来，确实有点特朗普的风格。
Like, I'll just try all of these angles.
就像，我把这些角度都试一遍。
I'm going to try all of that.
我全都要试一下。
Whatever sticks, but yeah, that was, I really liked that bold choice, where it's like, because there's two ways you can go with the story.
哪个管用都行，不过是的，我真的很喜欢那个很大胆的选择，就像，因为这个故事有两种发展方向。
One is like, Hey, show does seem cool.
一种是，嘿，这节目看起来确实不错。
I wonder where this is going.
不知道这会走向何方。
No, we say he's a criminal the moment you meet him.
不，我们在你见到他的第一秒就告诉你他是个罪犯。
So you just know the bit.
所以你立刻就懂了这个梗。
There's a joy sometimes in just telling the audience, and joy is an audience member, sometimes, even though comedy is surprised, sometimes it's fun to be like, this is the bit.
有时候直接告诉观众会带来一种乐趣，作为观众有时也是一种快乐，尽管喜剧在于惊喜，但有时直接挑明“这就是这个梗”也挺有意思的。
This is the bit, we're not gonna surprise you along the way, and we're gonna show this seduction, you're gonna know what you're watching the whole time, and there'll be a couple other surprises in other places, but that's not the surprise.
这就是这个梗，我们不会在一路上给你什么惊喜，我们会向你展示这场诱惑，你从头到尾都知道自己在看什么，其他地方还会有几个别的惊喜，但这个不是。
Well, also it's like, if you're a chef, you want a couple things on the menu that are like standards, like good comfort standards, like it's not for the mood for.
嗯，还有就是，如果你是个厨师，你会在菜单上放几道标准菜，比如那些令人舒适的经典菜，无论你当时想吃什么。
This is just a good stick, yeah.
这就像是一个稳妥的招牌，没错。
Do you know what I liked?
你知道我喜欢什么吗？
I like that you got Patrick Swayze to guest star without him actually showing up.
我喜欢你请来帕特里克·萨韦兹客串，虽然他本人并没有真正出场。
It was a hell of a cameo.
这真是一次精彩的客串。
You felt that cameo.
你能感受到那个客串存在。
You felt that.
你能感觉得到。
He feels how good he is.
他能感受到自己有多棒。
You feel Swayze.
你能感受到萨韦兹。
You feel off-screen.
你能感觉到他在画外。
He liked the wind.
他喜欢风。
You feel him.
你能感觉到他。
He's like the wind.
他就像风一样。
He is like the wind.
他真的就像风一样。
She's not like the wind.
她可不像风。
He's like the wind.
他就像风。
Do you know what?
你知道吗？
I think my favorite line in the episode was Cho saying, New York City Public School makes some parents nervous.
我觉得这集里我最喜欢的台词是乔说的那句，纽约市公立学校让一些父母感到紧张。
But the kids who walk out, walk out, crack.
但走出来的孩子们，走出来，太棒了。
The kids who walk out.
那些走出来的孩子们。
Walk out proud.
昂首阔步地走出来。
He hits that so hard.
他这句话说得真带劲。
He has a great, he really had a great part in this.
他演得真好，他在这一集里的确表现得很出色。
He really had like this go baby, if he really came, he kind of came as very guttural and his like seductive Mr. Marshall, but never trying too hard at all.
他真的有一种，来吧宝贝，如果他真的来了，他带着一种非常本能的、充满诱惑力的马歇尔先生的范儿，但却一点也不显得刻意。
He's really, it was like very much the, I'll make him come to me.
他真的，非常像是那种，我得让他来找我。
I'm not chasing this guy, I'm making this guy come to me.
我才不追着这家伙跑，我要让这家伙来找我。
Jordana was really genuinely horrified by Lily's credit card debt.
乔丹娜对莉莉的信用卡债务确实感到由衷的震惊。
Like she was like, this is really bad.
就像她觉得，这真的很糟糕。
No, it's bad.
不，这很糟糕。
It's really bad.
真的太糟糕了。
And I'm sure like with her psychologist cap on like, she really should have told Marshall that.
而且我确信，戴着心理学家的帽子，她真的应该把这件事告诉马歇尔。
That's why like it really is a big problem.
这就是为什么这真的是一个大问题。
Like she really did fuck up and she knows it and she's been hiding it.
她确实搞砸了，她自己也知道，而且她一直在隐瞒。
And I love that it doesn't get resolved in this one.
我喜欢这一集里并没有解决这个问题。
I love that it just, it's gonna keep going.
我喜欢它就这么悬着，事情还会继续发展。
It's a good ticking time bomb.
这是个不错的定时炸弹。
Barney making the case that porn is today Shakespeare.
巴尼提出色情片就是当代的莎士比亚。
Yeah, that was really good.
对，那段真的很棒。
I liked how nervous he was around.
我喜欢他在她面前表现得有多紧张。
Yeah, how we call himself Starnie Benson.
对，他怎么称呼自己为斯塔尼·本森。
Starnie Benson, dammit.
斯塔尼·本森，见鬼去吧。
By the way, the law firm of Nicholson, Hewitt and West, those are three dorms at Wesleyan.
顺便说一句，尼科尔森、休伊特和韦斯特律师事务所，那是卫斯理大学的三栋宿舍楼。
I'm looking at my who I met at Wesleyan and I met Carter Wesleyan.
我在想我在卫斯理大学遇到的人，我在卫斯理遇到了卡特。
I met my wife, Wesleyan, and those are three dorms at Wesleyan.
我在卫斯理遇到了我的妻子，而那正是卫斯理的三栋宿舍楼。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, you must know that, Josh, you're you're an honorary.
我的意思是，你一定知道这个，乔什，你是个荣誉……
I'm an honorary young, I'm an honorary young, I'm not alumni alone.
我是荣誉青年，我是荣誉青年，我不是正式校友。
Yeah.
对。
You must have an encyclopedic melon.
你的脑子里一定装了一部百科全书。
You know what?
你知道吗？
I was watching this and I think it's a really funny satisfying episode, but for me as an actor, I realized it's really, this is a Ted reactive episode.
我在看这一集的时候，我觉得这是一个非常搞笑且令人满意的剧集，但对我作为一个演员来说，我意识到，这其实是一集以泰德为被动反应的剧集。
Ted is not the driver of his own destiny in this episode.
在这集中，泰德并不是他自己命运的掌控者。
Something is thrust upon him to use that word again.
用刚才那个词来说，事情是被强加给他的。
It's thrust upon him and he just has to kind of deal with it.
事情强加到了他头上，他只能去设法应付。
Is that hard to play to be like that reactive?
要表现出这种被动的状态很难吗？
because it's true there's a kind of like kind of clearing his name is kind of a drive, but it's like a reactive drive.
因为确实有一种，比如说洗清罪名算是某种动力，但这是一种被动的动力。
Is that harder to play?
这样演会更难吗？
Yeah, definitely.
是的，绝对的。
I mean, it's not like, I just think the earlier episodes of this season in particular, and certainly the pilot, it's like he's got a huge want.
我的意思是，这不像，我只是觉得特别是这一季的前面几集，当然还有试播集，他有着强烈的渴望。
That sounds dirty, but you know what I mean?
听起来有点色情，但你知道我的意思吧？
He's got a motor.
他有一股驱动力。
And in this one, he was a little like this thing comes across his path that he has to deal with, like he has to remedy this thing.
而在这一集里，他有点像是恰好碰上了这件事，必须去处理它，就像他必须解决这个麻烦一样。
No, it is.
不，确实如此。
I was thinking about that.
我一直在想这件事。
There's no real drive.
这里面没有什么真正的驱动力。
It's kind of clear in name, but there's a nice moment of like protecting Kevin Heffernan's character's feelings.
洗清罪名算是一个，但其中有一个很好的时刻，就是去保护凯文·赫费南扮演的角色的感受。
I'm forgetting the actual name, not Ted Mosby.
我忘了他的真名了，不是泰德·莫斯比。
There's a not Moby, and others are not Ted Mosby.
有一个不是莫比，其他人也不是泰德·莫斯比。
Just the idea that when Kevin Heffernan is so sweetly, he's like, ah, no, you're not upset about this.
就是当凯文·赫费南表现得那么可爱时，他说，啊，不，你不是在为这个生气吧。
Sorry, I did this.
抱歉，我做了这个。
I did this as a tribute.
我做这个是为了致敬。
It was like, No, it's great like when you have to sort of like take care of him and realize oh shit I've got to not crush this guy cuz he did mean this well.
当时的感觉就像是，不，这很棒，当你不得不去照顾他的情绪，并意识到，操，我不能打击这家伙，因为他确实是一片好意。
I thought that was a nice Doesn't like hurting people's feelings What about when he said my father said just plant a tree in Israel The guy who actually saved you was named Lance Hardwood Yeah, that was fun.
我觉得那是个不错的细节，他不习惯伤害别人的感受。还有他说“我父亲说只要在以色列种棵树”的时候呢？那个真正救了你的人名叫兰斯·哈德伍德。
That's fun to play.
对，那很有趣。演起来一定很好玩。
I mean that was Ted's active moment in Yeah.
我是说那是泰德的高光时刻。
I liked when Marshall said the haze of cigars and scotch and Swayze.
我喜欢马歇尔说的，雪茄、苏格兰威士忌和帕特里克的迷雾。
Yeah.
对。
Oh, you know what?
哦，你知道吗？
You know what?
你知道吗？
I really liked a little cinematic, uh, Frime Mannion touch.
我真的很喜欢一点点电影般的，呃，弗兰姆·曼尼恩式的风格。
Mm hmm.
嗯哼。
Really?
真的吗？
In the American beauty shot with boots instead of flowers.
就像《美国丽人》的镜头，只不过把花换成了靴子。
Yeah.
对。
That was a really cool shot.
那真是一个非常酷的镜头。
I remember that was crazy because boots were being dropped on Alison Haddigan's face.
我记得那太疯狂了，因为靴子直接砸在了艾莉森·哈迪根的脸上。
Like I think she got hit in the face of him.
好像她真的被靴子砸到脸了。
She He is being like, there's no way to do that other than actually drop boots on Allison Haddigan's face, but it looked insane.
她……导演当时就像是，除了真的把靴子扔到艾莉森·哈迪根的脸上之外，别无他法，但看起来太疯狂了。
It was this giant pile of boots with like a gym, like a camera on a gym over her.
那是厚厚的一大堆靴子，头顶上架着一台摄影机。
Yeah.
对。
And it was like, I guess let's try not to hit her in the face with these boots.
当时的感觉就像是，我猜……尽量别用这些靴子砸到她的脸吧。
But also, I mean, it's such a clear reference to this iconic, you know, American beauty poster with Mina Suvari, which at the time, I mean, I don't remember that movie is 99, 2000, something around there.
而且，我的意思是，这显然是对那张标志性的、你知道的，梅娜·苏瓦里的《美国丽人》海报的致敬，那部电影当时——我不记得了，是99年、2000年左右吧。
But like, when you're watching it back then, it was unmistakable that that That was what the...
但当时看的时候，你一眼就能看出那就是……
Now it's like, what is that?
现在看起来，就会觉得：那是什么？
Yeah, it's just like kind of weird and interesting and cool, but if you don't know, you don't know.
对，就感觉有点怪异、有趣又很酷，但如果你不知道，那就是不知道。
But that was...
但那是……
That's the perfect topical reference, right?
那是完美的时事梗，对吧？
The thing that just has legs either way.
无论如何都能经久不衰的东西。
That's actually kind of great.
其实这真的很棒。
Yeah.
对。
You do not need to know.
你不需要知道它。
It was a reference to that.
它就是对那个的一个致敬。
I think it's funny how we consistently called Wendy the waitress Wendy the waitress.
我觉得搞笑的是，我们一直管温迪叫“女服务员温迪”。
Right.
没错。
If that was her last name.
就像那是她的姓一样。
It's like a children's show.
就像儿童节目一样。
It's in like Mr. Rogers world or something.
就像在罗杰斯先生的世界里什么的。
Or P.E.U.U's playhouse.
或者皮威的游乐屋。
It's very peaceful.
非常平和。
Yes.
是的。
Jerry, the chair, and Wendy, the waitress.
椅子杰瑞，和女服务员温迪。
I realize, of course, that a friend of the show, once again, Noah Garrison's life has been ripped from the headline.
我当然意识到，节目的老朋友，诺亚·加里森的生活再次被新闻标题给“剽窃”了。
We went to college with Noah.
我们和诺亚一起上过大学。
Noah goes back to elementary school with Alec.
诺亚和亚历克从小读同一所小学。
Noah really was an environmental lawyer at the NRDC, but was always like, you know, is that am I gonna be there forever?
诺亚以前确实是自然资源保护委员会（NRDC）的环境律师，但总是会想，你知道的，我一辈子都要待在这儿吗？
Am I gonna take a job with a bigger paycheck?
我是不是该去找一份薪水更高工作？
Am I gonna do something else?
我是不是该去做点别的？
And so we really based a lot of what Marshall went through on our friend, Noah, who Carter was friends with UBL in college together.
所以我们确实把马歇尔经历的很多事情，都原型化自我们的朋友诺亚，卡特在大学里跟他就是好朋友。
I wish I had asked him in advance to say something to us.
我真希望我提前让他对我们说点什么。
I didn't, but don't worry.
我没这么做，但别担心。
I asked him during the show.
我在节目进行中向他提问了。
Okay.
好的。
Was Coaching Little League, and still he sent this message into us.
他当时在带少儿棒球队，但他还是给我们发来了这条信息。
Hey guys, nice to be back on.
嘿，大家好，很高兴再次上节目。
I am literally taking a break jumping out from Coaching Little League here to say hi.
我真的是抽空从少儿棒球队的训练中跳出来跟大伙儿打个招呼。
When I was sort of making the decision about transitioning careers and making the junk to law school.
当我当时正考虑职业转型并准备跳槽去读法学院时。
I was spending a lot of time with Craig and his wife Rebecca and Carter at times.
我花了很多时间和克雷格、他的妻子丽贝卡在一起，有时还有卡特。
And it talked to them a lot about the job move and the change.
我和他们聊了很多关于换工作和转行的事。
And at the same time, Craig was telling me all about the sort of TV ideas they had and the writing they were doing.
与此同时，克雷格一直在跟我滔滔不绝地讲他们关于电视剧的点子以及他们正在创作的剧本。
Among all the ideas, all of a sudden, Craig told me that they had a pilot that was potentially going to shoot and that they were going to make one of the characters a law student who wanted to go into environmental law and wanted to follow the same path that I was following, hopefully one day working for the NRDC.
在所有的点子中，克雷格突然告诉我，他们有一个试播集可能要开拍了，而且他们要把其中一个角色设定为法学院学生，他想从事环保法工作，并想走跟我一样的道路，希望有一天能在NRDC工作。
And at the time, I didn't really think much of it.
当时，我其实没怎么把这当回事。
Craig and Carter had been doing successful writing, but pilots really didn't go anywhere that often.
克雷格和卡特一直在进行成功的剧本创作，但试播集真正能拍成播出的其实没那么多。
And then all of a sudden, they stole my life for nine years and broadcast it on television to a national audience.
然后突然之间，他们把我的生活偷去了九年，并在电视上向全国观众广播。
So thanks for that, guys.
所以谢了啊，伙计们。
But otherwise, hope things are going well and talk to you all soon.
不过除此之外，希望大家一切都好，回头再聊。
He really did work for the NRDC for years.
他确实在NRDC工作了好几年。
He never, God bless him, never sold out and went to work for some evil place.
上帝保佑他，他从来没有“向现实低头”去那些邪恶的机构工作。
He never did that move, but he is now a professor at UCLA.
他从来没有做过那种选择，但他现在是UCLA的教授。
So he's not, he did get out of the, the NRDC game.
所以他倒也不是……他确实退出了NRDC的圈子。
And he did, you know, it's, it's a tough, it's a wonderful gig, but it's, it's a lot of work.
而且你知道的，这是一份很艰难、很棒的工作，但也有大量的工作要做。
And he, but he teaches, he teaches about the environment and he teaches about law and like he's, he's out there doing good stuff and always has been, he's never been seduced to the dark side.
但他教书，他教授关于环境和法律的课程，而且他一直在做有意义的事情，一直都是这样，他从来没有被黑暗势力诱惑。
So go, go, go, you know.
所以，加油，加油，加油，你知道的。
I do love that the bit, you know, I'm going to work for the least evil place in the world.
我很喜欢那个梗，你知道的，“我要去世界上最不邪恶的地方工作”。
The news paper shots of like the horrors.
那些关于人间惨剧的报纸镜头。
It's good.
这很棒。
It sort of plants a seat if we're going to see Marshall go down this somewhat dark path this season.
这算是在为本季马歇尔走向这条略显黑暗的道路埋下伏笔。
And in a few episodes from now, we're going to see Ted do a little bit of that stuff too and spin out of control in his single dome.
在接下来的几集里，我们也会看到泰德做一些类似的事情，并在他的单身汉生活中彻底失控。
We've talked about how Ted has been a little more Barney-ish in this new single chapter.
我们之前讨论过，在这个新的单身篇章中，泰德变得更像巴尼了。
So it's nice to have Marshall and Ted on these kind of parallel tracks of slightly losing their souls at the same time in season three.
所以，让马歇尔和泰德在第三季里同时经历这种略微丧失初心的平行轨迹，感觉挺不错的。
And we're gonna see the kind of fuse that is lit, kind of continue and add tension and suspense.
我们将会看到这种被点燃的导火索如何继续蔓延，并增加张力和悬念。
And Lily's got the secret.
而且莉莉还藏着这个秘密。
So we, I feel like this episode is a lighter episode, but it did some good seed planting of things to come.
所以我觉得这一集是一集轻松的剧集，但它确实为未来的剧情埋下了很好的伏笔。
And a nice ending with Barney being the location scout for the scouting their apartment.
而且以巴尼作为看房侦察员来为他们的公寓踩点做了一个不错的结局。
I like the last thing, let's move this to the couch, they all pop up.
我喜欢最后那句“咱们把这个搬到沙发上去吧”，他们全都蹦了起来。
Yeah, that was a great reaction.
对，那真是个极好的反应。
That was hilarious.
太搞笑了。
Yeah, but you really had the machine of porn in the apartment.
对，但你公寓里确实曾经有一台色情机器。
That really happened Welcome back.
这真的发生过。欢迎回来。我们在用我们的C区来做收尾。
We're wrapping things up with our sea block sea block It's a podcast in eternal We obviously as you know love to open the show with a voice note from Fans of the of how I met your mother and we like to close with a written note From fans of how I met your mother and how we made your mother And if you would like to contribute in any way and maybe have your letter read on the air or played on the air, please go to how we made your mother.com slash contact, follow the instructions.
C区，一个永恒的播客。正如大家所知，我们显然喜欢以来自《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝的语音便签来开场，我们也喜欢以来自《老爸老妈浪漫史》以及《我们是如何创造老妈的》粉丝的文字便签来收尾。如果你想以任何方式做出贡献，也许想让你的信件在节目中被朗读或播放，请访问 howwemakeyourmother.com/contact，按照说明操作。
It's pretty easy to submit.
投稿非常简单。
We've gotten thousands of these letters and we're delighted to hear from you.
我们已经收到了数千封这样的信件，很高兴能听到你们的声音。
And here is the one for this episode.
这是本集的来信。
This is from Katie from Port Elgin, or Elgin, Ontario.
这是来自安大略省埃尔金（或译埃尔金港）的凯蒂寄来的。
Hi, after listening to the podcast episode from Instagram Live about Craig's book, I finally moved it to the top of my ridiculously big TBR pile and I listened to the audiobook this past week and wow, thank you Craig, thank you so much.
嗨，在听了关于克雷格书的Instagram直播播客节目后，我终于把它移到了我那大得离谱的待读（TBR）书单的最顶端，并在过去一周听了有声书，哇，谢谢你，克雷格，非常感谢。
Here is the review I put in story grid, wow, I am almost completely speechless, I rarely give five star reviews and here I am.
这是我发在Story Grid上的书评：哇，我几乎完全说不出话来，我很少给五星好评，而现在我破例了。
The audio was done so, so well, and the story is pretty much perfect, in my opinion.
有声书制作得太棒了，在我看来，这个故事几乎是完美的。
It is the right mix of heavy and funny, happy, and hard.
它恰到好处地融合了沉重与幽默、快乐与艰难。
As a parent of a child with complex needs, this one was personal and also very different from our family, too.
作为一名有着复杂需求儿童的家长，这本书对我来说非常私人，同时也与我们家庭的情况非常不同。
All in all, seriously, I would call this a must-read, audio, or visual, and just wow.
总而言之，说真的，我会称这是一本必读之作，无论是听有声书还是视觉阅读，简直太棒了。
As a bookstore owner slash operator, I am always hesitant to make really strong reviews as my insecurities kick in.
作为一名书店老板兼经营者，我在写非常强烈的书评时总是犹豫不决，因为我的不安全感会涌上心头。
But if they don't like it, what if I'm telling someone about a book I love, I'm making myself too vulnerable, etc.
但如果他们不喜欢呢？如果我向别人推荐一本我爱的书，而我自己却显得太脆弱了呢，等等。
And yet I can promise you that this summer and potentially fall in winter, your book will be my number one suggestion to everyone.
然而我可以向你保证，今年夏天以及潜在的秋冬季节，你的书将成为我向所有人推荐的第一首选。
Because it is one of the few books I think can be universal, maybe I'm wrong.
因为我认为这是为数不多的具有普世价值的书籍之一，也许我错了。
And also the parts of my soul that recommending it lays bare seem okay.
而且，推荐这本书而让我的心灵裸露出的部分，似乎也觉得没那么糟糕。
All in all, I can't thank you enough for writing it.
总之，我真的非常感谢你写了这本书。
And if you are ever in small town, rural Ontario.
如果你有机会来到安大略省的乡村小镇。
for the major important book, major important book, that can be of general interest, general interest, even with its touchingly private glimpses of life, private glimpses of life.
为了这本具有普遍意义的重要著作，即便它带着那些令人动容的私密生活吉光片羽。
Thank you.
谢谢你。
A million times over.
万分感谢。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Katie, thank you.
凯蒂，谢谢你。
A million times over.
万分感谢。
Thank you.
谢谢你。
A million times over.
万分感谢。
I can't.
我真的……
Now I'm speechless.
我现在说不出话了。
Thank you, Katie.
谢谢你，凯蒂。
Confession.
坦白讲。
I mean, that's just I'm now I'm speechless.
我是说，这真是……我现在说不出话了。
Thank you, Katie confession.
谢谢你，凯蒂，坦白讲。
I am Katie.
我就是凯蒂。
I wrote that I don't even know what that is.
我写了那些，我都不知道那是什么。
I thought the Ontario bit was really smart.
我觉得安大略那个梗真的很聪明。
I know I threw in a lot of red herrings to make it seem no My god, that means the world to me Alec Thank you for sandwiching this episode with an amazing opening that spoke to my soul and this person who read my book And then my book spoke to her to her like it that just that means the world to me how much I'm other fans and fans of podcast are the best.
我知道我加了很多烟雾弹，让人觉得——天哪，这对我的意义太重大了，亚历克。谢谢你用一段走入我灵魂的精彩开场白来夹心这期节目，还有这个人读了我的书，然后我的书触动了她，就像——这对我来说意义太重大了，我们的粉丝和播客粉丝真的是最好的。
You guys are my target audience.
你们就是我的目标受众。
I'm so thrilled that the book is speaking to you Katie and to other people and the audiobook that Josh and Kobe are two of the four narrators is amazing.
我很高兴这本书触动了你，凯蒂，还有其他人，而且乔希和科比作为四个旁白中的两个，有声书真的太棒了。
Josh is exquisite at this.
乔希在这方面简直绝了。
He's so good at narrating an audiobook.
他太擅长录制有声书了。
It's ridiculous how good and Kobe's amazing.
好得离谱，科比也很棒。
So yeah, that means the world to me.
所以，这对我意义重大。
I just can't thank you enough.
我真的感激不尽。
And I will say, you know, if you love how I met your mother and clearly, if you're listening to this, you do.
我要说的是，如果你喜欢《老爸老妈的浪漫史》，显然，如果你在听这个节目，你一定喜欢。
You will love Craig's book.
你也会喜欢克雷格的书。
That's not how it happened.
《事情才不是这样的呢》。
It is the same kind of beating heart, the thing that people love so much about how I met your mother and they keep returning to it.
它有着同样热烈跳动的心脏，正是这种特质让人们如此热爱《老爸老妈的浪漫史》并一遍又一遍地重温。
The DNA is in that book as well.
那种基因也存在于那本书中。
It's its own thing.
它有它独特的风格。
It's a standalone thing.
它是一部独立的作品。
But I cannot recommend, just like Katie, I can't recommend that that book highly enough.
但我怎么推荐都不为过，就像凯蒂一样，我对这本书的推荐怎么都不为过。
So if you haven't listened or read it, please do.
所以如果你还没听过或读过，请务必去看看。
You will, you will not regret it.
你绝对、绝对不会后悔的。
Thanks, man.
谢谢你，老弟。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I don't know what to do.
我不知道该怎么办了。
This is made my day.
这让我今天过得太开心了。
This is too good.
这太棒了。
I should just go to bed.
我应该直接去睡觉了。
Nothing's getting any better than this moment, but we're going to, I'm going to go live more life.
没有什么时刻能比现在更美妙了，但我们要——我要去好好生活了。
It's going to all be downhill from here.
从这以后都要走下坡路了。
Thank you guys.
谢谢你们，伙计们。
Honestly, there's a bunch of hymium sort of references and Easter eggs in that book.
说实话，那本书里有很多关于《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的彩蛋和致敬。
So pick it up if you're a hymium fan.
所以如果你是《老爸老妈》的粉丝，去买一本吧。
I hope you like it.
希望你们会喜欢。
And yeah, I'll, I've said it before And I'll say it again, Hymmium and Hymmium have both things have the best fans ever.
还有，我以前说过，我还要再说一遍，《老爸老妈》和《老爸老妈》拥有世上最好的粉丝。
Thank you guys so much.
非常感谢你们，伙计们。
Yeah, we'll see you next time.
好的，我们下期再见。
Thanks for joining us.
感谢收听。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请宣判我无罪，所有的罪孽都被原谅，在纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《How We Made Your Mother》由乔希·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由Office Ladies Network和Audyssey呈现与发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
本节目还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利担任执行制片人，由我，亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）制作和剪辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是A·点蓝色工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯，我们的Gen Z大师、数字内容制作人是艾米莉·布隆伯格，助理制作人是凯瑟琳·格罗夫。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面插图由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在Apple Podcasts或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
That really does help to spread the word.
这确实有助于让更多人听到我们的节目。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔希·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供伴奏音乐。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萨姆·西博尔德和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅乔希·拉德纳的 Muse Letters，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐及其他作品。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com.
在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的处女作小说《事情才不是这样的呢》，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 阅读他的其他已出版作品。
And you could subscribe to my own dead father's society on Substep.
你还可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“死去的父亲协会”。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何为本节目筹集先天性心脏病研究资金的持续公益活动贡献力量，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，我会跳舞。